Connie is with us in Sioux City Iowa hi
Connie how are you hi and finding how
are you better than I deserve what's up
in your world um straight to talk to you
my husband and I are both in our mid 50s
for long time a few followers we're
debt-free except 260k mortgage last
retirement is flooded we believe through
either an assault plan or my husband and
I both have 401ks
College for our children is done our
emergency fund is done o go way to go
way to go yeah we've done really well
we're a married couple with four kids
between us and we've been married for
about 12 years
um I've recently left work a couple of
months ago and I would like to not
return to work oh he's kidding come is
enough to pay the bills the mortgage and
things like that but what I'd like to do
is when I was working we had money but
no time now we have some time that we
have no cash I would like to take
$100,000 traditional Roth and pay down
our mortgage paid off even outside that
hundred K traditional Roth we we still
have significant retirements on and
since we are debt-free and just to give
us some more time
Oh older 150s
and our retirement fund is when you say
significant funds in your 401ks and
other retirement non Roth what are you
talking about how much money about two
and a half two and a half what naen okay
yeah and the Roth it's not there's no
such thing as a traditional Roth it's a
Roth or a traditional I'm sorry the
traditional IRA not a rod okay well
you'll be penalized right to pay off the
mortgage yep and um you don't have any
other cash you have access to this not
in retirement funds well we do have an
urgency v how much is in your emergency
fund we have thirty thousand in our
merchant for sure household income about
a hundred and twenty okay and you don't
have any other investments of any kind
that are
not in retirement no we don't we just
paid for a wedding which has been hard
we've gotten in four kids for college we
do have some money with $10,000 left in
that basement remodel fun oh so you know
it's it's just we would just like people
you don't have any stocks you don't have
any other mutual funds that are not in a
retirement you have two and a half
million in your retirement we yeah we do
have a lot of we do have a lot every
time that were significantly funded and
I believe yeah well it mathematically
doesn't make sense to do it although I
get where you're coming from peace of
mind and just be done with it because
it's a drain on your cash your ten
thousand dollar income and no I wouldn't
have you return to work or to earth two
and a half million dollars seriously
done but to go back to work just to pay
the mortgage off it is whose name is the
traditional IRA in my husband when does
he turn 59 and a half uh he's 55 so
three and a half years yeah yeah what
kind of four and a half years actually
gonna happen alright isn't 55 when did
he turn 55 December so it's December
he'll be 50 say okay so he's at 55 and a
half and so it's exactly four years from
right now right right all right I'm just
trying to think through it because it's
either that four years or you're going
to pay on your tax rate which is 35 or
40 percent or maybe 42 percent plus a
10% penalty so it's 52 percent mmm it's
what you're paying to borrow this money
to do it four years early that just
makes me want to grow up yeah and I
guess I didn't feel our tax rate was
that high but I know it's a 10% your tax
rate is that high he makes a hundred and
ten thousand yeah yeah it might be might
be 35 but I mean you're paying 50
percent approximately and taxes and
penalties
it's like borrowing money of 50 percent
interest just today we're going to owe
them sell taxes on it at some
but oh but yeah we would put it with it
would allow us to have some time in
essence all to tell a question because
the taxes are due at some point anyway
but it you know it is in a sense our
present value of that as well but and
aside from that that's a minor issue the
okay so we're talking about 6,000 bucks
mm-hmm in penalties to get 60,000 to get
60,000 out plus your tax yeah right
right you're okay you're gonna take a
hundred runs like a hundred out to get
clear sixty right if you want to do it I
wouldn't you got to a half million
dollars I mean nobody's gonna yell at
you for anything you do you've done a
great job I mean you've done a great job
just for a math nerd like me it's just
very hard I'm always going to try to
figure out some way to keep from giving
the government that extra money but I
don't but it's a six thousand dollar
thing and you keep saying gives you the
time gives you the time but you've got
the time I mean it's just a matter what
you're going to do with it the payment
on that sixty thousand dollar mortgage
isn't that big
yeah well it's twelve hundred bucks yeah
whoo I would almost rather have you take
now what's the house worth Oh
totaling up to forty two thirty okay one
thing you could I mean you can do it if
you want to it and you know you know
what the cost is and if he knows what
the cost is you've earned the right to
do this it's not that big a deal it's
like by now if you call me up and said I
want to buy a nice car that's a hundred
thousand bucks for the car the car is
going to lose six thousand dollars as
soon as you drive it off the lot I would
tell you to do it because you've earned
the right to enjoy it and so if you want
to do this you've earned the right to
enjoy it okay and it just I always just
fight back against that a concept of
giving the government money more money
yeah but um now here's one other idea
you could go get a home equity loan on a
fixed interest rate mmm-hmm with a as
long a term as possible where the
payments were almost nothing mm-hmm
until you hit the four year mark mm-hmm
and coast out that interest however is
going to cost you something during that
time it's probably six thousand dollars
so that's probably a wash it's probably
that's not probably would do it I just
might have to
hold my nose while I did it but I
probably would do it yeah and it would
be great to be able to have you know
he's got a lot of vacation time just to
have that extra time and I really don't
want to return to work I don't have to I
don't think yeah I mean you have to at
million I think you're in good shape
yeah awesome awesome thank you very much
do you attribute having the two and a
half million to where did it come from
what do you tell people's they say how
could I do that um you just you say for
both financial peace followers we have
recent children that just got married
blood spots in both Financial Peace
University
oh we just did you did you inherit a
bunch of money no no I'm sorry my
husband's company is a stock company
okay and they do very well okay so some
of it came for his income to the company
but most of it was just from having us
at lifelong pattern of saving very cool
very very cool hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show so you have to break
the cycle you have to flip this thing on
its head and make it behave you've got
to get so fired up and wired up that
you're broke friends think you've lost
your mind
you